aquí tenemos una gráfica del decaimiento
exponencial donde n se refiere al número
de núcleos radiactivos como función del
tiempo muy bien y la ecuación que se
encuentra por acá arriba es justamente
la que describe la gráfica que tenemos
de este lado así que la ecuación nos
dice que el número de núcleos
radiactivos en cada momento del tiempo t
es igual a n 0 que representa el número
de núcleos al inicio que multiplica a el
elevado a la menos lambda donde cabe
aclarar que el lambda es la constante de
decaimiento es la constante de
decaimiento y como su nombre dice es una
constante es un número fijo y que por
eso muchas personas les gusta escribirlo
con una letra k verdad podemos llamarle
acá por ejemplo si estamos pensando en
una tasa constante pero bueno lo
importante es que solo es una constante
y luego lambda hay que multiplicarlo por
t que en este caso representa al tiempo
y digamos que quisiéramos encontrar
quién es este valor que se encuentra
aquí arriba es decir donde la
intersecta al eje vertical verdad
entonces lo único que tenemos que
fijarnos es que eso corresponde a cuando
el tiempo es igual a 0 cuando la
variable t es igual a 0 entonces si te
es igual a 0 lo único que tenemos que
hacer es digamos colocarlo dentro de la
ecuación y podríamos calcularlo así que
el número de núcleos al tiempo cero será
igual a n 0 x era la menos lambda que
multiplica a cero es decir n cero será
igual
más bien en evaluado en cero será n sub
0 por e a la 0 verdad menos lambda por 0
es simplemente cero y cualquier número
elevado a la cero es 1 así que el número
de núcleos al tiempo cero es justamente
lo que conocemos como n 0 por eso es que
decimos que n 0 es el número de núcleos
radiactivos que teníamos inicialmente
muy bien así que esta altura de aquí
digamos es justamente n 0 y en realidad
podríamos haber hecho exactamente lo
mismo con cuál
el valor del tiempo verdad si nos
fijamos en un valor del tiempo
particular que nos interese nos fijamos
en la gráfica verdad y vemos cuál es el
valor de el número de núcleos para ese
valor del tiempo verdad entonces aquí
sería el valor n en particular podríamos
haberlo hecho para el valor de la vida
media y recordemos quién es la vida
media la vida media que la vamos a
denotar como de un medio es un valor del
tiempo para el cual el número de núcleos
radioactivos sería la mitad de los que
teníamos inicialmente entonces en este
caso el número de núcleos radiactivos
sería los que teníamos inicialmente
dividido entre 2 muy bien sería la mitad
de lo que teníamos inicialmente es decir
lo que nos resta es la mitad de lo que
teníamos inicialmente muy bien así que
fijémonos en nuestra gráfica fijémonos
en n 0 y dividamos esta altura entre 2
entonces digamos más o menos aquí se
encuentra
de n 0 y si nos vamos a la gráfica y
después caemos hacia el eje del tiempo
aquí tendremos el valor de un medio muy
bien la vida media de este tipo de
núcleos muy bien así que vamos a tomar
estos dos números y vamos a
considerarlos en nuestra ecuación del
decaimiento exponencial verdad y de
hecho vamos a ponerle un poquito más
abajo vamos a ponerlo aquí copiamos la
ecuación tenemos que en ete n dt s n 0 x
a la menos lambda t muy bien entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es ahora sustituir
este valor del tiempo de este lado y
vamos a sustituir este valor de n del
lado izquierdo y vamos a ver qué es lo
que obtenemos entonces tendremos lo
siguiente del lado izquierdo tendremos
en 0 entre 2 que será igual a n 0 x era
la menos lambda
un medio muy bien y si nos fijamos
podemos simplificar esta expresión
verdad porque podemos dividir entre n 0
de ambos lados y eso hace que se
cancelen y lo que nos resta es lo
siguiente un medio será igual a ea la
menos lambda de un medio verdad la vida
media y ahora qué es lo que podemos
hacer con esto ahora lo que podemos
hacer es calcular el logaritmo natural
de ambos lados tendremos logaritmo
natural de un medio sería igual al
logaritmo natural de ea la menos lambda
de un medio y porque el logaritmo
natural bueno pues porque el logaritmo
natural cancela la exponencial verdad
cuánto será el logaritmo natural de un
medio podemos sacar la calculadora
calculamos logaritmo natural de un medio
1 entre 2 muy bien y eso nos da menos
0.6 93
vamos a dejarlo menos cero menos 0.6 93
y esto será igual al logaritmo del
exponencial se cancelan y nos queda
menos
de un medio entonces simplemente podemos
deshacernos de los signos negativos
verdad multiplicando por menos uno de
ambos lados y tendremos 0.6 93 igual a
lambda de un medio aquí viene lo
interesante podríamos decir quién es la
vida media en términos de la constante
de decaimiento verdad por un lado si
dividimos entre lambda de ambos lados
tendremos que la vida media será 0.6 93
dividido entre lambda muy bien esta
sería la expresión de la vida media en
términos de la constante de decaimiento
pero al mismo tiempo podríamos
determinar quién es la constante de
decaimiento en términos de la vida media
verdad simplemente de la expresión
anterior dividimos entre la vida media
de ambos lados y obtendremos que la
constante de decaimiento sería 0.6 93
dividido entre
un medio verdad entonces lo que podemos
observar de estas dos expresiones es que
en tanto nosotros tengamos la
información de la vida media podemos
calcular la constante de decaimiento o
al revés si tenemos la constante década
de decaimiento podríamos calcular la
vida media muy bien vamos a hablar ahora
de las gráficas semi logarítmicas aunque
que es otra forma de fijarnos en la
información en los datos así que vamos a
hacer un poco de espacio hagamos un poco
de espacio voy a reescribir la ecuación
que ya teníamos el número de núcleos
radioactivos al tiempo que será el
número de núcleos iniciales por qué a la
menos la constante de decaimiento por el
tiempo muy bien ahora lo que vamos a
hacer con esta expresión es tratar de
convertirla en una línea recta así que
lo que tenemos que hacer es dividir
entre n 0 de ambos lados muy bien
tendremos n dividido entre n 0 será
igual a a la menos lambda
y ahora vamos a usar el logaritmo
natural nuevamente verdad tendremos
logaritmo natural de n dividido entre n
0 es el logaritmo natural de la
exponencial elevado a la menos lambda t
muy bien entonces tendremos que el
logaritmo natural y la exponencial se
cancelan y del lado izquierdo podemos
usar propiedades del logaritmo logaritmo
de un cociente es el es la resta de los
logaritmos muy bien entonces tendremos
logaritmo de n - logaritmo de n 0 es
igual a menos lambda de muy bien y
finalmente sumamos el logaritmo natural
de n 0 de ambos lados y tendremos que el
logaritmo natural de n es menos lambda t
más el logaritmo natural de n 0 y si
somos muy observadores esto ya tiene una
forma como de una recta si recordamos
las rectas tienen la forma de igual a mx
más b cierto entonces a que corresponde
cada una de estas expresiones con
respecto a lo que tenemos en la recta
bueno en nuestra
variable que corresponde a el logaritmo
natural de n verdad en este caso la
pendiente que es la variable m
corresponde a menos lambda y t que es la
variable del tiempo corresponde a x
finalmente la constante b corresponde al
logaritmo natural de n 0 entonces esto
se puede ver como una recta y una de las
variables importantes de las rectas es
la variable m verdad que es la pendiente
de esta recta muy bien y recordemos
también de paso que la constante b
corresponde a la ordenada al origen de
la recta así que vamos a esbozar
rápidamente cómo se ve esta gráfica
digamos tenemos aquí el eje vertical y
el eje horizontal muy bien digamos en el
eje horizontal voy a poner entre
paréntesis x y pongo entre paréntesis x
porque no nos interesa x nos interesa la
variable que tenemos acá arriba verdad
que esté la variable t es la que nos
interesa mientras que en el eje vertical
que voy a poner entre paréntesis
en realidad la variable que nos interesa
es logaritmo natural de n muy bien y
entonces vemos que la ordenada al origen
es decir donde intersectan la recta a
este eje tendré el valor de logaritmo
natural de n 0 y eso es muy fácil de ver
simplemente lo podemos demostrar
rápidamente si te vale 0 tendremos que
el logaritmo natural de n será igual a
menos lambda por 0 más el logaritmo
natural de n 0 pero bueno menos lambda
por 0 nos da cero y nos queda que
entonces el logaritmo natural de n es el
logaritmo natural de n 0 entonces este
punto es la ordenada al origen y después
trazamos nuestra recta que tiene una
pendiente negativa verdad de hecho tiene
una pendiente menos lambda esta recta
tiene una pendiente que de hecho sabemos
cómo calcularlo verdad es el cambio en g
dividido entre el cambio en x y eso es
menos lambda entonces lo que hemos
graficado aquí es justamente una gráfica
semi logaría
a veces solo se dice se me love y es se
me love porque por un lado tenemos la
variable normal y en el otro eje tenemos
el logaritmo natural verdad estamos
comparando la variable original contra
el logaritmo natural de la otra variable
y eso nos da mucha información verdad es
sólo otra forma de fijarnos en los datos
podríamos calcular la pendiente de esta
línea recta y esa pendiente sería menos
lambda verdad si tomamos el digamos está
pendiente con número negativo lo que nos
indica es la constante de decaimiento
muy bien entonces la constante de
decaimiento se puede obtener aquí y con
esto podemos obtener la vida media así
que nuevamente para remarcar las
gráficas semi logarítmicas son una forma
distinta de fijarnos en los datos